KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I came
out and I have to ask,
what exactly is going on?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Well, Katie, I think
I made the perfect chocolate
chip cookie recipe,
but I'm having issues with
portioning and assuring
each cookie will bake
and taste the same.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I mean, the
dough looks pretty good itself.
I'd love to get the recipe.
But as for portioning,
I have some tools here
that might be able to
help you get consistency
with each cookie.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that would be great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I didn't know
you were an amateur baker as
well as being a software dev.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's right.
When my code is done, I turn
it over to the customer.
They then deploy it in
their cloud project,
according to a long list
instructions that I've written.
But the problem is that
these deployments often
turn out like my cookies--
uneven and not very good.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: That
does sound frustrating.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
It makes the customer unhappy
and makes me look bad.
I know my code is correct, but
if it's deployed incorrectly,
it won't work.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Have
you considered using
an infrastructure as code tool?
Instead of your documentation,
you could write it all as code.
Then you get
repeatable deployments
in a machine-readable language.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, sounds great.
What's the tool?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
There are several.
But one that's widely used
right now is called Terraform.
It supports many
major cloud platforms,
including Google Cloud.
Let me give you
an example of some
of the benefits of
infrastructure as code.
This gcloud command will create
a Cloud Storage bucket for you.
But if you run it again,
you'll get an error
that the bucket already exists.
You could add manual checks
around this command to ask
if the bucket already exists
and create it if it doesn't.
But when you start adding these
checks around all your scripts,
it gets complex
and unmaintainable.
MARTIN OMANDER:
So with Terraform,
I won't have to write
so much shell code?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Exactly.
In Terraform, you describe
your desired state--
a bucket exists in your project.
Applying the Terraform
manifest will
check if the desired
state has been met.
If the bucket already exists,
Terraform will take no action.
If the bucket doesn't
exist, Terraform
will take the steps
required to create it.
MARTIN OMANDER:
But what if I have
things that are different
between deployments,
like Google Cloud project ID?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: You write
Terraform manifests in HCL--
HashiCorp Configuration
Language--
which allows for
such complexities,
like variables and
calculated fields.
Terraform will also work
out the dependency graph
itself when working
with multiple resources.
Some resources have to
be created before others,
and some resources
create data that will
be used by other resources.
For example, if you have
a Cloud Run service that
relies on a Cloud
Storage bucket,
the bucket has to exist
first and Terraform
will work that out.
If you have, say, a
deployment of five Cloud Run
Functions that are
independent of each other,
Terraform will run
those creations
in parallel, which will be
much faster than creating
each of those one by one.
MARTIN OMANDER: Can I configure
other Google Cloud products
with Terraform?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Of course.
It isn't just limited
to serverless products.
With the Google
Terraform provider,
you can deploy virtual
machines, networking,
and other complex
infrastructure that
would be downright annoying and
frustrating to have to manually
deploy over and over again.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, nice.
So could Terraform also
help me with setting up
test environments?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: I mean, sure.
Just consider what needs
to be different in test.
You may want to add some
variables to, say, create
a smaller Cloud SQL
instance, rather
than a production spec one.
But with Terraform, you can
easily create duplicate setups,
much like a cookie cutter
in your baking adventures.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds great.
Can I also tell Terraform
to build my containers?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well,
Terraform deploys existing
assets, like containers
or compiled code.
It presumes these
resources already exist.
There are a couple of ways
that you can get around this.
You could have your existing
artifact creation process
and then manually run
Terraform when required.
That works well
if, like you said,
you deliver your
code to a customer.
Or you can add Terraform to
your existing automation,
for example, as a step in your
Cloud Build configuration.
This works well if you're
doing in-house development
with continuous deployments.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I should
convert the long list
of installation instructions
in my readme file
to a Terraform manifest?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: It's
probably a good idea.
Not only will your
deployments get more reliable,
you can store your
live infrastructure
configuration settings
along with your code
in source control.
I've left some links in
the description for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I will read up on that.
So could you show me an
example of a Terraform
manifest for a serverless
web application?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: How about
we catch up next week,
and sit down and work
with some Terraform code,
and try deploying a few things?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, that
would give me a better
idea of how Terraform works.
Let's do it.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]